one of the scariest
things about finding out your spouse has
cheated on
you one is that picture you have in your
head of her having sex with somebody
else right there's that very visceral
reality thinking about that over time is
a choice you can't help the lightning
bolt the image that just shoots in your
head you can choose to hit play on that
videotape that's looping in your head
okay okay that's number one the worst
part is realizing what you're realizing
in slow motion right now you missed it
yeah for two years your wife's been out
of this thing and you didn't know and
you were bus in your butt to get
certified you've been busting your butt
to give her a better life by driving
right